info ou intox et avec anthony st léger
bonjour bonjour les jeux olympiques de
pékin en sont un exemple flagrant 1 face
au co vie 19 la chine choisit des
protocoles sanitaires drastiques voire
paranoïaque effectivement et c'est dans
ce contexte c'est anxiogène il faut bien
le reconnaître que depuis quelques
semaines une vidéo connaît un certain
succès sur les réseaux sociaux elle est
présentée comme l'un le dernier exemple
des mesures sanitaires en vigueur dans
les écoles chinoises on va la découvrir
ensemble regarder elle a été vue plus de
120 mille fois une dizaine de secondes
on aperçoit des enfants portaient des
combinaisons de taïkonautes ans et le
long des astronautes chinois est très
vite dans plusieurs langues et bien
l'inquiétude se lit sur les tweets les
internautes trouvant cela assez exagéré
un peu dans la veine de ce qui s'est
fait ces derniers temps veux-t-on les
rendre fous nous dit par exemple cet
internaute en espagnol et d'ajouter
serait ce la nouvelle stratégie pour
contrer la croissance est démographique
il y à aussi la réaction de cet italien
tout simplement la folie chinoise
jusqu'où allons-nous accepter tout cela
s'insurge ce français est cet autre
internaute de conclure cela doit
vraiment être mauvais pour leur santé
mentale nous dit il ici et d'ajouter que
c'est une la dernière farce du peu vide
19 en chine mais alors justement une
force ou cette vidéo et l authentique et
bien elle a tout ce qu'il ya de plus
authentique cette vidéo elle existe
réellement sauf que comme souvent elle a
été sortie de son contexte c'est que
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ont repérer ac a
rapidement certains twittos comme cet
internaute qui nous dit on voit des gens
en font à 6 et ce en masse ce sont des
déguisements ils doivent être à une
sortie scolaire et bien bingo c'est la
recherche d'image inverser une fois de
plus qui nous met sur la piste mais
cette fois google s'est avérée
totalement inefficace rien de probant
puisque il nous renvoie uniquement vers
des publications qui relate justement
cette version d'enfants chinois portant
une combinaison sanitaire direction donc
bye d'eau puisque on est en chine le
moteur de recherche chinois et nous
atterrissons assez rapidement sur des
articles comme celui ci qui relate
l'événement en question et bien il
s'agit d'un événement sportif en chine
dans une école primaire il a été
organisé chante grauss et dans l'est du
pays et nous sommes le 2 décembre et les
enfants ont été déguisée ainsi ou rendre
hommage à l'industrie aérospatiale
chinois c'était le souhait du professeur
du directeur de l'établissement rien à
voir donc avec le co vide 19 et des
recherches supplémentaires nous amène à
des vidéos même publié par la chaîne
d'état chinoise cgt n on y voit vous
voyez les mêmes costumes on va remarquer
aussi que les spectateurs ou parents
comme comme en font d'ailleurs n'ont pas
de masque et cet événement identique on
le retrouve aussi dans une autre école h
anglais dans l'est également même
costume mêmes raisons une fausse
information qui a tout de même une part
de vrai or il n'y a pas de fumée sans
feu comme on dit et la rédaction des
observateurs de france 24 amenez-le
enquête elle les médias chinois ont
documenté de cas d'enfants qui ont porté
ce type de costumes effectivement pour
se protéger du coville 19la en avril
2020 on se souvient qu on est en
première entre plaine première vague de
l'épidémie le père de l'enfant en
question avait modifié le filtre à
l'intérieur de cette combinaison est le
second cas c'est lui regarder à raphaël
le cas devenu célèbre pour sur les
réseaux sociaux en janvier 2021 je sais
pas si on peut voir la vidéo à l'antenne
on le voit déambuler dans les rues de
nantes on sait dans l'est de la chine et
ses parents lui ont affublé ce petit
costume décidemment qu'on ne voit pas
l'antenne il ya vraisemblablement voilà
on y arrive voilà le costume en question
donc ce lucas qui déambulent dans les
rues de menton dans l'est de la chine
selon ses parents cela le protégera
efficacement du virus sont en janvier
2021 on rappelle un critique a cité
scientifique n'a pas été avérée merci
anthony st léger c'était info ou intox
avec anthony